a bombshell report by propublica reveals
just how little the wealthiest americans
have been paying in
taxes propublica obtained more than 15
years of never-before-seen irs
information
about the 25 richest americans and found
that sometimes they paid little or no
federal income taxes that includes
warren buffett
elon musk and michael bloomberg also
jeff bezos who is now the richest person
in america
he paid no zero zip zilch federal income
tax in 2007
and then again in 2011. we reached out
to all of them but have not heard back
buffett and bloomberg did respond to
propublica saying
that they support an increase in taxes
on the wealthy
and that they donate much of their
wealth to charity now we should make
clear
that none of the things that these men
did is
illegal which is actually part of the
scandal here and the irs says it is now
investigating the source of the leaked
documents
remains to be seen if congress will take
a look jesse eisinger
wrote the article along with a colleague
and he joins us now to talk about it
more
uh jesse you write in the piece that
this explodes a cornerstone myth of
america that idea that we all pay
our fair share how were these wealthy
americans
able to avoid something as basic as a
federal income tax
yeah thanks for having me tony so what
we wrote about
is exactly that that the super wealthy
the ultra wealthy
are completely out of the system most of
us
have salaries and the taxes get
extracted out of the salaries
we are in the american tax system but
the way
the super wealthy work that jeff bezos
is in the elon musk's of the world
their way their wealth builds they are
outside of the system so their wealth
builds up and it's untaxed
and then only it's tax when they sell
they choose when to take income
sometimes they don't take income at all
they don't take wages and
it's only taxed when they sell and they
often don't sell they borrow to fund
their lifestyle so for the average
americans sitting at home they get paid
on a friday
the federal government is very good
about taking money out of that
check but not so good it sounds like
taking money out of the overall
wealth and assets the stock the homes
the cars the art the yachts you name it
of super wealthy americans is that the
basic picture of things
that's the basic picture exactly so
warren buffett takes
very very little income and he only pays
10 cents for every hundred dollars that
his income grows
the average american making sixty or
seventy thousand dollars
a year they pay fourteen percent so
they're paying fourteen dollars of every
hundred dollars that's coming in
so it's completely different picture for
the wealthy the wealthy take
very little income even that income is
taxed very low at low rates lower than
someone making forty five thousand
dollars
but the bigger picture here is that the
whole world of their wealth
what confers their power what they're
able to contribute to
political campaigns charity
what enables them to keep control their
companies that's
untouched by the tax system so carl
eichen who's a multi-billionaire
he's an investor he responded to
questions from you guys at propublica
and he said look
it's called an income tax i may have
billions in the bank or through this
wealth but i didn't get any income so
why should i pay taxes what's the
response to that
yeah it's pretty uh astonishing uh
admission i enjoyed talking to carl
uh about that and he's exactly right
we're writing about the system that
doesn't
tax um this kind of wealth now take carl
for example he had hundreds of million
half a billion dollars of income
in 2016 2017 income by the irs
definition
but then what happens is carl icahn's
business is his personal
uh fortune and his personal income taxes
his business income tax it's all mixed
together
so he borrows a huge amount of money to
invest in companies
and that gives him leverage and explodes
his returns
and then he pays interest on that he
gets to deduct that interest so that
half a billion dollars of income
got wiped out from the interest payments
in other words you and i and all the
taxpayers in america
are helping carl icahn borrow so that he
can have better returns in the stock
market
yeah you know people should know if you
add up all the wealth in america make it
one big old pie
the super wealthy are getting most of
those pieces the rest of us are getting
fractions of a slice and the bottom
fifth of our society are getting crumbs
or actually they have zero pie they're
oh they owe pie they're in debt
uh jesse eisinger this is a landmark
piece of reporting from propublica it's
the first in a series you guys are going
to be doing
i look forward to each and every entry
thank you for joining us